التوقع حول الجدل السياسي أه أه
داخل إسرائيل أو الصراع داخل
إسرائيل هو أن كل ما رأيناه
قبل 7 أكتوبر سيظل
موجودا بعد انتهاء الحرب ستظل
هناك صراع بين ما
أسميه دولة يهودا وهي
دولة المستوطنات أه التي تريد أن
ترى إسرائيل أكثر تديناً أكثر
ثيوقراطية أه
أكثر تعصباً وإسرائيليين أكثر علمانية أن باراك
مثلاً يمثل هذين النموذجين
الآخر أسميه دولة
إسرائيل الصراع بين دولة
يهودا دولة المستوطنين في
دولة تل أبيب إذا أردت أيها
أكثر تعددية وأكثر ديمقراطية فكلتا
الدولتين ليستا ديمقراطيتين بالنسبة
للفلسطينيين فهما
ديمقراطيان فقط، حسنًا في حالة دولة
إسرائيل فقط  لليهود وليس
للفلسطينيين لذلك أعتقد أن هذا
الصراع اليهودي الإسرائيلي الداخلي أه سيستمر
بالتأكيد نتنياهو أه سينهي هذه
الحرب أضعف بكثير مما كان عليه من قبل ولكن
علينا أن نتذكر أنه لا يزال لديه
قاعدة قوة داخل إسرائيل قد لا تزال
تدعمه  وقد يخسر
الانتخابات المقبلة لكنه قد يعود
مع هذا الرجل، وهو
أمر أكثر أهمية بكثير من نيتان، فالقضية ليست نان، القضية هي أن
لدينا مجتمعًا يهوديًا إسرائيليًا
لن يغير مجتمعه.  الموقف
تجاه فلسطين والفلسطينيين
وهذا هو ما يقلقنا للغاية ومن
أجل تغيير الواقع لا يمكننا أن
نتوقع تغييرا من الداخل. ما نحتاجه
هو كما قلت من قبل وسأقول ذلك
مرارا وتكرارا نحن بحاجة إلى
ضغط قوي قوي من  المنطقة ومن
المجتمع الدولي إذا كنتم حقاً
تريدون إنهاء المعاناة أه
الاحتلال والاستعمار